so I love a mighty wind I love waiting
for government but here's my thing I
laugh the entire time and I don't I know
you're an actor so like you're supposed
to be able not to laugh but how did you
not laugh in all those scenes well I I
did you I did but but it what
particularly in waiting for Guffman
because that was the first one yeah and
because Chris guest who I kind of
co-wrote the movies with and Chris
directed them and Chris is one of the
funniest guys yeah you're so bad
yourself yeah well he had my number
let's put it that way
so his character Corki st. Claire was
just so funny that every time he was on
camera I would
I would laugh he would get me laughing
so there was a group of us in most of
the scenes and I would move myself
behind the group as the scene was being
shot dropped on my hands and knees and
crawl off the scent so nobody would
notice like that I was laughing in the
middle of the scene and I would
virtually disappear and and as you don't
want to ruin the scene well that's the
thing yeah you because it's
improvisational in nature you know what
you're doing that's really funny
off the top of your head it's really
hard to go back and recreate that if you
laugh in the middle of a funny scene
then they say cut okay boy that was
going so well let's go back and try that
again it changes things so we learned
it's it's better not to laugh no matter
how funny you think something is I
didn't wait a Guttman I was crawling off
the set more times than you can count
Homer Simpson gift that just backs up
into the bush like I just got a knock
run this that would be so backing up
into the bush that was like in gut when
there was one scene that was one of my
funniest scenes it's a group where we're
onstage during our final show at the end
of the movie and a train is supposed to
be pulling away
and what we do is we're standing there
watching the train and we kind of go
like this all right subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going